(upbeat instrumental music)
- Hi, I'm Hannah, your
friendly neighborhood wine mom.
And if you're anything like me,
you believe that a
glass of wine at 8 p.m.,
or a glass and a half,
makes you a better mom.
So pour yourself a glass
and let's talk about stuff.
But today, first, let's talk
about while, (speaks gibberish)
(outtake beep)
But first, here's why
I'm drinking tonight.
I dunno if you noticed,
but I'm dressed up.
Because we have a very
special guest today.
There is a wonderful
gentleman here to teach us
a little bit about wine, so
let's welcome Christopher Webb,
our fancy wine man! (clapping)
- Hello.
- Everybody cheer. (clapping)
- (laughs) My name is Chris Webb
and I am a sommelier at
a restaurant in Malibu.
Essentially what I do is help guests find
the wine that they are going to enjoy.
- Good day with a sommelier.
(Chris chuckles)
(sad foghorn)
I feel like you're used to pairing wines
with pretty fancy food.
- Steak, lobster, caviar.
- Caviar, oh my god.
I have two kids.
I don't really eat that.
Is there any way we could
do a couple pairings
with some of the foods
that I typically eat?
- Yeah, I mean, I've brought
some wines here, we can.
- I like you already.
He said "I brought some wine."
Okay, so first, I feel like
you're supposed to drink
wine with cheese, so
I brought some cheese,
I raided my son's lunchbox.
- Ah.
So the first lesson of pairing
wines with food in general
is if it grows together, it goes together.
- Ooh!
- So if, there you go!
- Ho ho!
- Right?
So, the home to mozzarella
cheese in Italy is Campania,
so any Campania Red will do.
- Just a little bit
more.
- More?
- Just a little, just a squirt.
- Alright, so, first step,
a little swirl, right?
Oxidates the wine so that you can
get all of the wonderful aromas.
- I smell red wine, for sure.
- Mm-Hmm.
- What?
(Chris slurps)
(Hannah laughs)
(Hannah slurps)
- There you go.
(Hannah chokes)
- I'm just trying to be fancy.
(Chris spits)
Oh, what the heck are you doing?!
Why would you ever spit out wine?
- Well, because if you don't spit it out,
you're never gonna make it
through the entire tasting.
- We don't waste wine in this house.
- (laughs) Okay.
- Okay?
I eat baby puffs a lot for lunch.
- What are baby puffs?
- This.
(puffs rattling)
Honestly, they don't
really taste like much.
Is there anything that I could have
that would add some flavor to these?
- My choice for this one would
be Australian Chardonnay.
New World Chardonnay,
which is United States,
South Africa, Australia,
those sort of places.
- Wait, are we learning history now, too?
Mm-hmm.
- I think it kinda works.
- Mm-Hmm.
- I actually like that.
- Yup.
When my kids aren't around is when I enjoy
all of my treats and my wine.
So is there a wine that
will go with ice cream?
- Yes.
One of the main things
you wanna keep in mind
when you're pairing wine with dessert
is that it always has to
be as sweet or more sweet
than the dessert you're having.
- I have some ice cream sandwiches.
- Okay.
- This is the easiest dessert
to sneak if you have kids.
- Okay.
- Because you can just,
like, shove it in your shirt
and walk into the bathroom with it.
- I didn't put these in
my shirt, don't worry.
- Okay.
This is a dessert wine,
it's Moscato d'Asti.
It's not very expensive,
it's a good value,
and it can pair with
just about any dessert.
- Cheers.
- Hey!
- Right?
- Alright!
- Oh my god.
- Right?
Some of the flavors and
aromas that I get is,
like, honeysuckle, white peaches.
It kinda reminds me, oh, thank you.
- So, before we go to the next one,
do you mind, like, I love
that we're being fancy
and dressing fancy, but my stomach,
like, starts to pooch a lot.
Do you mind if I change into some sweats?
- No.
- Okay.
You can take off your jacket, too,
if you wanna be more comfortable.
I'll be right back.
Okay, so.
I'm totally not hitting
on you, by the way.
I'm married.
I'm literally just changing
into something more comfortable.
So, as a mom, a lot of the
time your meal is gonna
consist of whatever is
left on your kid's plate.
So I'll eat pizza crusts
from my kid's plate,
but a lot of the time it
doesn't have a lot of flavor,
so is there a wine that's gonna bring out
the flavor of the pizza crust?
- Yes, so this is Lambrusco.
Not a lot of people know about it.
- I've never heard of it.
- It's actually slightly sparkling.
It's very food friendly.
It can go with just about anything.
- So, here's, my son, he is clean.
He doesn't have any cooties.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
- Are you grossed out my the pizza crust?
- Uh, no, um, it's.
- He stopped eating his
boogers like six months ago.
It's cool.
Last.
Sometimes I only have about 15 minutes
to myself to drink my glass of wine.
(claps) What's the kind of wine
that's gonna go down the fastest?
- Well, not that I would recommend
chugging wine, or drinking.
- You don't have kids.
- But if, I guess if I was gonna choose
something that would be easy to drink,
my go-to would probably be rose.
Rose all day.
- Rose all day.
- There you go.
- I feel like this is a sign,
because rose is my favorite wine,
and he just said it's the most drinkable.
Cheers.
Should we try to chug?
- Uh.
- And, go.
Oh, that was a bad idea.
Woo! (laughs)
So, that's all I got for today.
I feel like I learned a lot.
So, special thanks to
my fancy guest, Chris.
We're best friends now,
we're wine friends.
So if you don't mind topping me off
with a couple extra sips.
- Sure.
- I'm gonna.
- There's not a lot left, I don't think.
- We gotta do this again.
We gotta do this every week.
Till next time, I'm Hannah,
your friendly neighborhood wine mom.
I'm just gonna enjoy a
couple of sips with my BFF!
Do you ever get a burp, like, stuck.
- I actually can't burp.
- And you don't know if
it's going up or down.
What?
- I can't burp.
I've never burped in my entire life.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Do you just fart? (laughs)
- Everybody farts.
- (laughing) Not girls.